where we're going to begin uh
with triangles is with the simplest kind
of triangle that we can work with
okay so even though trigonometry uh
deals with all kinds of triangles which
means it deals with circles and any
other kind of repeating thing
like acoustics or radiation all that
kind of thing we're going to start
simple and then build from there
okay so identifying sides of right angle
triangles
let's draw one let's just draw a right
angle triangle like so
okay so you've got a triangle that looks
something like that
now we want to be able to talk about
triangles
and use a common language right the idea
is a bit like you know
tailors you know they write down those
those four numbers okay but they know
those four numbers refer to particular
things
they refer to this circumference and
that length and so on okay
and then if someone that tailor gave the
numbers to another taylor
they would know what they're talking
about because they've got this common
language so
we're gonna establish some common
language for triangles okay
now just by convention if we just label
this a little bit
we usually call the corners of a
triangle
by capital letters
and we also usually call the sides of
the triangle
by lowercase letters we tend to name
them like this
see how this one's capital a in this
corner the one that's opposite
we name it little a okay so this one's
capital b so the one opposite that
is little b and the one opposite capital
c
will be little c okay which is why when
you first learn pythagoras's
theorem which is not what we're doing
today but it's clearly it's related
we usually write it as a squared
plus b squared equals c squared right so
you can see the c
is the long one over there okay all
right now
just on that on that pythagoras theorem
idea this c right it's special
it gets a special name right we call it
the hypotenuse
so
this is the hypotenuse over here right
so we name it that side now we want some
names
for these other two sides and the way
we're going to do it
is we want to think about like this is
about triangle measurement okay
in particular the big core idea here is
that if you know the sides
it tells you something about the angles
and vice versa just like if i know
something about my neck circumference
you automatically know something about
my height and my shoe size blah blah
blah okay
so here's what we're going to do we've
sort of run out of letters
we've got lowercase ones here we've got
capital ones here
to refer to a particular angle i'm going
to go to a different alphabet so i'm
going to call this angle over here from
the corner
i'm going to call it theta okay so this
angle here
that's how you spell it if you're
curious i said i'm going to another
alphabet this is the greek alphabet
okay you're going to see a whole bunch
of greek letters
um theta theta you'd appreciate that
uh theater is written like a a zero
right
and then it's kind of got like a tail in
the middle kind of like a cube at the
tail's in the wrong spot
okay that's theta you're gonna meet a
whole bunch of other ones
like i'll i'll introduce them as we go
okay but that's theta
right now we've got the hypotenuse
labeled over here okay now i want you to
put yourself in the position of
this angle over here like as if you're
standing there like suppose theta is on
suppose it's you okay now from this
vantage point
i can name these other two sides for
instance
see this one lowercase b right see how
it's next to where you are
right i know the hypotenuse is next to
you as well but we've already got a name
for that
okay you hold on you know but not
everyone else does right
so since it's next to you it's adjacent
to you that's another word for it i'm
gonna call this one down here
the adjacent side adjacent
okay that just means you know next to
you
okay and the same way remember you're
standing over here your theta
okay when you look across to lowercase a
right this side is is facing you it's
opposite you okay so we'll call this one
the opposite side okay
um or if you like the facing side
so this line if it's your neighbor and
this one's over the other side
okay here's the important thing uh and
it'll help if you draw yourself another
triangle exactly the same just next to
it
okay here's the same triangle
still got a and b and c still got little
a
little b and a little c okay now this
time i'm going to put another angle in
right instead of theta over there okay
i'm going to have a look at this
opposite angle up here okay so i'm going
to call this one
alpha so i've got theta let's build our
alphabet shall we alpha
okay now now that i'm over here
right the perspective has shifted a
little bit right now now you're standing
up here
okay um c lowercase c is still the
hypotenuse
it's always the hypotenuse the one
that's opposite
the right angle is always the hypotenuse
so we never need to worry about what
he's called
okay but um this side over here
we called it the opposite before right
but it's not opposite anymore
yeah it's the adjacent side to you to
your angle
right so now this one is adjacent
they've swapped around
can you see that uh and this guy down
here when he's swap two he's the
opposite now
okay so here's this important idea that
the hypotenuse always stays put
but these two they're kind of relative
to where you are
right just like when you say oh who's my
neighbor it's like well it depends where
you're sitting
right you've all got different neighbors
just like each angle has a different one
okay